whoop-whoop so baron you're wearing that
dude I'm wearing the best damn Analytics
band in the world it measures your sleep
message your recovery measures strain
and measures basically it measures your
heart rate and everything else how many
calories you burn pretty much everything
to the nth degree right yeah it's the
best man I'll cycle my dad today which
was gone an hour hike we got lost it two
hours and my dad goes oh we've walked
over 10,000 steps that's probably about
three and a half miles and now he had
his he Herson of the whoop no it wasn't
no didn't have anybody you got a
different editor a different we had is
it something else on yeah and he goes oh
it's about three something miles I said
how many calories think we burned dad
hears I don't know price six hundred and
I brought up uber I've been I just
because you can track it right when
you're gonna do a workout you can decide
swimming weightlifting running biking
psych whatever you gonna do I put
Uther's hiking I put hiking I did it
right when we started and I had exactly
how far we went how many calories we
burned our heart rate our average heart
rate our max heart rate it may be a T
but I was like Jesus I'm like telling
you man we need to get you one of these
cuz I'm Tom about woop there's no one
better in the game to measure your heart
rate also you can also as a with your
professional athlete just a regular
person when you're working out you also
know what day's the best days for you to
really train hard what days to rest it
Mars your sleep it does all of it yeah
it's got a battery life too so you know
I thought but the battery just slip on
you just slip it right on your charges
slip it off you don't enough take this
off really no that's how good it is mam
usually lasts about five days mine
laughs a little less a little longer
it's heart rate monitoring and then some
join the club right now you guys get $30
off your first purchase by going to
whoop calm that's wh-whoa Pete calm use
the code fighter at checkout and save
$30 and optimize the way you train
that's fighter for $30 off at whoop calm
happy and everyday by the way I hit
somebody today with have him world I did
too
that's so weird you did that
I did it to my dad unless he got so
offended of course he did
Oh a dad should be Memorial Day hike you
know what Memorial Day hike is Canadians
I said the same [ __ ]
happy Memorial Day I'm confused my
friend was like it's Labor Day you
[ __ ] not to idiot I was like sorry I
yeah I know
two idiots amongst your smart know what
Labor Day signifies people that work
take a day off yeah but so new doesn't
work or son who doesn't take days off
jolts hey hi everybody new special now
explain it to us because I want to get a
lot of stuff but just let me have a lot
of talk about just start off first with
explain 35 minutes of your hacen ated
with your okay so I wanted I'm following
in your footsteps yeah okay I like as
far as like social media I also just
like I look zombies I like that he's
gonna let he's releasing this on YouTube
yeah so yeah talked abut a little bit
about last time but I'm learning from
the young ones yes yes yes yes yes
I'm here for you man yeah yeah I just
did a I released a new special on my
youtube and it's uh it's like 35 minutes
no material nothing planned I just did
you know crowd work I just went up there
and ripped with the audience I sorry
she's very good thank you aunt Thanks
funny it's funny man yeah and thank God
that audience in DC which is a great
spot shout out DC him oh yeah D say were
there to play us do this yeah they were
cool with it I got a great [ __ ]
audience yeah you're good yeah I thought
that what else is brilliant that I
thought that you did is you release it
the same day Chappelle specially came
out had to well I think most people
would go hold up the greatest of all
time is really special yeah I'm gonna
wait two weeks
nah but you went boy get the opening the
video goes you know Chappelle's drama
special dude you should do yours like
same day he does it let's see what
happened yeah that was good yeah we know
we were gonna take that comedy is like
Chappelle was like everything was so hot
and then it would go yeah oh you watch
that I've seen Andrew Schultz and then
was like it was like this [ __ ] Herc
yeah it was like an album drop yeah I
was weird many people drop albums back
in the day knows yeah you listen to
Kanye's then you listen to fit these or
you listen to whatever like multiple
albums will come out on the same day I'm
thinking about taking my greatest hits
like after just like two four hours of
[ __ ] I love this going taking my
greatest hits
redoing them shooting at me
Wow and putting them up oh you need oh
oh you mean that fifty doing like the
penguin impression attractor yeah oh
that is interesting because I'd actually
be curious to see like I just did I'd
like to try them now
oh yeah but kind of outgrown them but
you do like can you but what if you took
the special you shot gonna do I could do
it what about the question is just give
me a little weird it's just a little
weird your age to go back side feel bit
yeah yeah like I could do it and I feel
like I could add stuff to it and make it
contemporary sort of you know I'm like
that makes sense yeah do it but I would
like to see the comparison to but that's
just a fun thing to do it's a fun things
I'm gonna do and you just put it out on
YouTube yeah the beauty of it yeah like
you have control when you drop that you
do whatever the [ __ ] you want but I like
yeah yeah you're like the you're
supposed cuz you have special on show
time where else all right what's show
time and then just Amazon and the same
thing you know and but do but you never
grow you get those back now yeah so I
mean you could dice all that up and put
the kind of cannon back there they're
owned by comedy dynamics but Brian Volk
wise to butter your mind so I'm sure
he'll give you clip yeah you know yeah
but for sure yeah your but yours has
been going well but because you'd it's
crazy man like we're over half a million
now I think we put out a little less
than a week
oh it's in the mail dog yeah I told you
that I take show it you must be feeling
so good it's so well it was cool it was
them it was the thing that's been most
shared by people for me I think because
the the world we live in now it's not so
overproduce and it's like yeah it's it's
your talents at the highest level where
I think when what when you get a special
you know that comics done that set yeah
100 thousand times who's exactly he's
doing no matter who it is
yeah so I think by you going up there
and you're like now let's see what
happens
yeah I think that's why people [ __ ] with
it cuz their profits it's a lot yeah I
need the stakes are high yeah and also
like it's too many people [ __ ]
thinking like you guys felt that way
like just so many think pieces about
everything like there's that we were
just talking before us a think piece
about the popeyes chicken it's like it's
just constant think pieces and and I
knew when Chappell was gonna drop
there's gonna be a million think pieces
so you know it's funny about that is it
sitcoms yeah there was a who the [ __ ]
was a Trey Parker the guy just yeah and
I think he was saying he said what
happened is I'm sorry if I'm quoting if
it was him but I think it was just he
said sitcoms for a long time were a
twelve year old would come in and say a
snarky line mm-hmm that a bunch of 35
year old professional writers took a
week to relay and and so she'd come and
say something that obviously a 12 year
old wouldn't say but haha that's the
funny yeah after a while audiences get
hip to that formula yeah that's that
kind of comedy gets dated yeah and
comedy like anything else starts to get
dated then all of a sudden somebody
comes in and does something new like an
improv show or whatever it might be The
Sopranos comes along everybody was like
wait a minute you got a mom who's
[ __ ] having panic attacks yeah well
as the game right it changes for the
better a hundred percent for the better
it just things things do go out of style
after walking about that today I was
thinking about how you can at my age you
you know look you can get people to
laugh it becomes a bit of a bag of
tricks but I'm interested in doing
something people haven't done before I'm
still interested in doing that yeah I
want to do something like when I do this
long monologue about my dad you know
being a tyrannical piano teacher it's
good it's moving into other territory
yeah there's room for that now cuz it
gets somewhat traumatic when people
[ __ ] love it yeah he loved watching
something theatrical or something
different sometimes yeah what you have
people's attention you could take them
penniless I think that's what we learned
to Chappelle that's right like like if
you if like Chappelle's a goat you know
don't get me wrong he's a living go
right and and like if you but if you
watch his special it's the most pleasing
thing to watch because you could just
listen to it yeah you actually might not
laugh that much but you'll enjoy it but
your interest to the best order of our
generation the best storyteller and
every little piece that he gives us has
a cool fun ending and you learn
something and you learned some and he's
also articulating feelings that people
have like he's the first he's the first
major comedian I think to like really
come out against the PC [ __ ] like like
but he's the biggest of the big go do it
obviously Rogan has done it on different
platypus man different
right here's what's everyone's sensitive
about check this out right and like to
be honest that was I mean last time we
spoke I was here probably right before I
drop views yeah that was the point of
views right views from assist the last
special is just like I'm going to
specifically target these things you're
not supposed to talk about [ __ ]
don't grab and [ __ ] me too you got a
trouble for some of those writing do you
know what I didn't really like I've got
more way more trouble now that people
know me than when I first dropped that
because the the point of that was like
yo we can laugh as [ __ ] do burger honey
yeah it'll albert has an abortion bit
yeah yeah I'm not gonna go into it we
were watching it like this ever
yeah and I said I talked to him we just
did that that charity I know I said well
I go yeah I go bro yeah well you're the
only one that can get away with that
[ __ ] he goes no I'm not no I'm not all
of us can and all of us should because
it's only you're talking about 3% of the
[ __ ] who are the loudest yo social
so that's a narrative I don't good know
so that's the thing this is this really
important about you know basically what
what I want to show with this special
right like anytime we released a special
is because I feel like I gotta address
something that's happening right how
many have you done and you so I had the
first one that was only like 15 it was
part of like an hour but that was for
for one that's where I did the four
different clubs really night chopped it
up yeah and then I deduce from assist
that I was the one who's really going
against a PC [ __ ] and then the crowd
work special now and what I want to show
in the crowd work special is like I got
a very diverse audience I probably got
the most diverse audience and in comedy
right and the point of the crowd work
special was I'm gonna make fun of every
different race gender religion in the
crowd and they're gonna laugh and
they're gonna show you that we could
laugh at ourselves yes it's that it's
literally five girls with short hair on
the internet that are making everything
a big deal but it has in no way the
general opinions not the opinion here's
a look at how we already offended if you
watch it all that we have angles from
the back you can't be offended on behalf
of the Indian guy the front row because
he's laughing
it's brilliant shot because you see from
the back viewpoint you see what they're
seeing and they see what yours you are
comment you an an audience member when
he wants to like when he's roasting like
there's there's four black girls and he
saw my double date
like he's they got from Nigeria is like
I'm supposed to know that [ __ ] races if
I was like oh you're from Nigeria but it
but third died and then the Mexica on
the back who do I don't mean give all
your [ __ ] away just references you know
this is purposely I'm not even girl in
the back doesn't want kids right that
would you know what you have come like
this [ __ ] knock out of the park
yeah this Maxine chick says she's don't
like kids so there's like it four
million see them it's it's specifically
done why but by the way next connect
Colombian Indian they need and that's
American by the way when you see
Americans work together I ever worked in
a [ __ ] like you've been in a five
army when I worked in a bank anywhere
you work in a [ __ ] restaurant that's
what Americans work really well together
and they're from all different but I
make fun of each other non-stop here's
the reason why you get well you know
you're allowed to do this and people can
enjoy it and I say it all the time with
if you just pay attention to social
media which so talk violent and the
loudest [ __ ] is on there ya can try to
you know this blah blah blah but when
bad girls your short hair that girl
short volunteers and they're not a
single or fat or skinny or males which
can get [ __ ] guys you can't get laid
right and fat girls that can't put their
hair in a ponytail correct those are the
two groups of people to have opinion if
you don't shut up [ __ ] up and they dye
their hair purple and all this kind of
[ __ ] [ __ ] they are fat is being and
they have these big opinions about
[ __ ] everything but no one really
cares no no where's but don't allowed us
on the internet because they're actually
the same size as everyone else in life
they're way bigger it's also a lot of
media but not really but but the thing
is is you but all both you guys know all
three of us know is when you're on the
road you've seen real people in Oroville
and spoke in washes and [ __ ] working
America Salt Lake Washington DC
washington DC they're good people who
are not prejudiced don't know that but
that Butler DOMA Julie there and you see
they don't they don't give a file my
favorites not a ballet you're great
people we're in LA right now and I live
in New York and it's like you know LA in
New York like liberal elites they love
to do this thing where they like make
quality people in the south and I
conservatives such racist right but like
every time someone calls the police on a
black person for bar
or like selling water where does that
happen always only knew where the [ __ ]
does that happen when we knew Alabama no
Oakland yeah right it's New York City
Mississippi right it's never Texas I do
think that a lot of is coming out of
elite academic institutions and a lot of
the media for people who've never really
had they they've liked one of the things
that somebody said yes to one of those
woke super woke white journalists said
do you know anybody who works with their
hands or anybody in the military
or anybody is there any bit of your
phone whose smoke yeah yeah who works
with their hands Jamie this count and
she was like and it that's that's the
thing to me there was all this uproar
yeah but anyone that you taught anybody
talk to it
go [ __ ] them side I'm rebellious oh I
suck yourself a member of Isis and me
toes and rock star movement got him is
that right oh they're so cell phone I
forget how much money and then all the
we went hold up
oh we're telling secrets now and the
interesting but also like they used to
be so cutting [ __ ] corny dude vice to
me was a bunch of dudes from [ __ ]
Maine they moved to New York City
because they thought they were the
coolest person in Maine and then when
they moved to Brooklyn they were like oh
now I'm here I'm one one's a proud part
of it he's like the main Gavin yeah yeah
yeah a lot of just got really weird but
I like dinesh d'souza who's kind of a
conservative I mean see what you will
about I don't know much about him but he
said he was talking about prayin and
going no no he's a he's a he's a yeah
political commentators yeah he made a
lot of money and he huh he does his
speeches and he's he's all these college
students were talking about the wall and
how evil of Wallace I don't know I don't
really think wall I don't think the wall
is effective down in Mexico but I'm just
saying although he said way right but he
said he said something the effective he
goes like this he goes yeah you guys are
all so vocal about the wall and stuff do
you you do realize you're in Princeton
which it has the big
wall you live behind huge walls now you
can't see the wall but nobody gets in
here the wallet smelled money the
essence you have yes and you're gonna go
from here on to Walter to huge these
jobs enjoyed against it eagerly speaking
you the biggest behind the biggest we
can't get in here correct yeah it's all
[ __ ] like I appreciate them you're
wait speaking of walls yeah speaking of
all it's the biggest wall on the planet
is a place called El Cap ah here we go
great Brian just watch free so long as
they sleep well just got your credit
card out there like a board or you can
flip that point is mixed Damon I think I
think it was great they did it you know
Chappell came out and he had this
amazing special where he like spoke to
feelings that everybody had and it's
great to see the top of the business do
that because that trickles down and I
guess I guess the I guess what I wanted
to achieve what the crowd were special
was you know do something there was a
little different but also show I don't
like to tell as much as I like to show
does that make sense yes like I feel
like telling doesn't really work does
showing does like like you're never
gonna have any pieces written about how
offensive this was because you can't
tell the person that I'm making fun of
how to feel correct
right like if you don't see the audience
exactly if you don't see if you don't
see the audience and I'm telling some
black joke you could be a black writer
and type some article about fences yes
but when you see the Nigerians in the
crowd laughing because we're talking
about these two tribes from Nigeria you
know on the Yoruba yeah Hausa and the
euros yeah and it's like like you can't
tell them to be offended because it
proves they're not yeah and that was the
idea about this is like let's stop
putting all this [ __ ] attention on a
five people that are offended and let's
go back to the 99.9% of us they'll
actually like [ __ ] up jokes enjoy
humor need humor and our [ __ ] lives
and this is the example of it and here's
the other funny thing about racism that
we drop it a lot yeah yeah if we could
all be the same color we'd all find
reasons to hate each other but for
example in Nigeria just a quick side
note the ebo yeah and then there's the
Yoruba and I'll set but the Yoruba are
the main tribe yeah and the ebo tend to
be like yeah this is joke where you'll
never find an ebow doesn't have five
degrees who's the [ __ ] doesn't have
like their their lawyers doctors - yeah
it's like education education but the
ebo were always the ones that were
oppressed in Nigeria the ebo were always
in the Biafra wars they were always the
ones that were basically slaughtered and
marginalized and so the 9-ball are the
[ __ ] they're the minority of Nigeria
so even in countries everybody's the
same color believe me believe me they
have their own art issues oh yeah always
it's human beings us versus them now
back to there's some free soil ebo chick
with short hair complaining right now
you know by you so offensive you can say
these things about us now about what we
are dentist so what they uh that's a
good that's a very good that is very
good dosa
thank you free solo thing it's over I
wanna make a statement go ahead it's
already been made it came out a year and
a half I think it was in theaters I know
yeah I honest I've been I'm late to the
draw he hasn't seen it yet I know the
point I make a point like do you need to
see the whole thing to sell yeah you
really don't make it to the top
no first I guess I got a theory he makes
it to the top makes it to the top and he
took in my opinion it might be the
greatest athletic feat I've ever seen
that you've ever seen yes
okay I've ever witnessed only because
there's no margin for error and that the
price is life or death okay you know
that job is gonna make an argument fall
you know and when he had to make that
move I wouldn't compare that athletic
achievement the same as to like a
basketball or baseball what want to make
one Harrison things just how much higher
it's a different it's just different
though it look I think what you're
trying to say here the argument is the
same Argan I make for Michael Phelps and
why he isn't the greatest athlete ever
that all
that I agree because how many people
have swam it's just that when you have a
common people had a swimming pool you
have to learn how to do that butterfly
take the pool of people that are I
anticipate Oh st. bolt undeniably the
most dominant athlete in history because
everybody has run 100 meters
everyone wants to run everybody has done
it and if you're good as a kid they
point you sleep at athletic feats when I
understand so no there's a difference
because by Herman by human yes so in
other words so in other words for me the
stakes the horse race truly life and
death with one more error there was a
lot it was a good one with ropes yep
fine with ropes in some of these moves
and one move he had to step on a tiny
little like a little rock baby put
brought fibers here yeah and if he had
missed he would have died and everybody
has done that and most people including
him kept dying and everybody's ever free
soul has died so it's so insane that I
don't know of any other sport where the
not only are the states that high the
physicality it's three hours and 50
minutes and you have no margin for error
yeah that's where I think it was the
craziest thing and nobody who's ever
stock climbs disagrees like everybody
was like this the craziest yeah that's
like when rock climbing is really
different like when people say comedy
comedies the hardest thing and all of us
comics like oh yeah 100% totally know
that though without ropes when you're
you're 3,000 feet up is the most insane
thing how do you do it's insane that my
only thing is is he took a trial run
with I'm not discrediting before I go
that's the move right but he so he took
it you took several trial runs before
with a rope so you learned the path he's
climbing don't fail in times that's
right the only variables now he's doing
it without a rope yeah he's done that
same route I agree to be designed no
one's done it before just do me wrong
phenom liar come on that he's done that
exact route there's no variable rocks
not moving right the path isn't
different and he's doing the seventh or
tenth line worth mattress without move a
50-ton he's done a 50-ton here's the
thing about so now I just took the rope
box yeah yeah Marcin beer I understand
it's crazy
that's it blood and he kept falling even
with your signal he did on that move
it's crazy it's great yeah but yeah this
thing's wrong there's no variable that
mountains can be the exact same whether
he does it this year ten years the wind
yeah you know no one is it ok if they
measure everything they make sure it's a
good day no one's ever dealt try it
Lyman and it's also three hours and
thirty nine of them it's climbing three
hours in the meadow I'm in dude like
high level mountain climbers no because
they all died right well there are a lot
of there a lot of professional mountain
climbers but nobody not really cared
other sports there's that mute I'm about
but that's not relevant to the fact that
do you have it for that but yeah let me
ask you a question if you were an elite
athlete would you climb so I [ __ ]
sports you can play to make money I
don't think he did that great upper body
straight be a weird kid no just gonna
climb his body rocks all day long he's
no it's what you do when you're
borderline [ __ ] there's nothing else
I could possibly drive you're basically
a monkey you're one step above monkey
[Applause]
sure on the spectrum of human he lives
out of endless in nature no no there's
this guy's a monkey yeah do you know
those videos Michael Rapaport always
posts with him walking around with the
monkey yeah that's him
yeah he's michael radford has a him he's
a mum he also hasn't routes personal
personna prasanna Pastrana Pastrana has
oh well you don't have fear and you're
getting a bull or some [ __ ] yeah Jamie
my knowledge it but it doesn't work the
way it works on yes she said your I'll
take him to the Bronx some Navy SEALs
have it like certain guys some fighters
have it yeah but not to Travis or his
his level yeah he said something really
interesting about fear though he said
it's not like I want to die or I'm not
afraid I just expand my comfort zone by
doing it over and over and over and over
and over again
practicing Tom yeah so so when you've
been doing it that much but the climate
network they also did Studies on him and
they found out that the fear receptor in
his brain doesn't trigger the same as
you and I he's a huge he's unique zoo
the major advantage that you excite now
your stop sweating he's all too uniquely
oh he's a ho no his fingers were like a
table as a kid yes his fingers started
to spread out and its toes are wider
yes while we were playing like he's in
[ __ ] girl healing bananas on the raw
this guy's our money but yeah okay he
was peeling bananas and mangos his
entire life still you think he's not a
monkey I think if we just get a picture
what's more impressive Michael Phelps
him my foe but yeah because Michael
Phelps is just I mean look at that guy
Sam he's a [ __ ] he's a samurai look
at that look at those hands mazing human
being yeah he's an amazing did you see
looks like an alien
you know what's [ __ ] crazy a monk is
when they get up like tier 1 tier 3 yeah
and they're sleeping those 10 just
swinging like what are you doing oh and
how about home we have to take a [ __ ]
we're just like dude how's it going over
there [ __ ] off the side
wait I thought it's one way up he's just
doing three hours well that what they do
is like they like you like if you and I
are in the mountain you're gonna set
your tent up there they out there I set
up here and then you take it down and
come back to my side and go up you know
I'm saying wait a minute I'm sorry it
takes multiple days to get to the top
because in my opinion Rehema guy it took
three hours and 50 minutes oh so he did
one day yeah now they do a cap in a day
but sometimes a lot of people take
smaller if they're not as good but he
was trying to plan his route yeah so
you're like chilled for like three weeks
got you okay so that's just eight like
Power Bars you have to be a very I think
mainly people get addicted to mountain
climbing because apparently if you put
you in that state of flow where it
requires all of your attention yeah that
that level of focus is it nothing can be
in your head no he's such a stud yeah
but then you hear him talk about his
friends like Ryan did fall off the other
day and died yeah but he really doesn't
care does he well I don't know for
anything but nights think he's on spec
he's the extreme he's the best athlete
ever not athlete or that's no I don't
think he's outing his body type would be
great for a lot of sports right right so
so I don't know what his forty is I'm
not talking about athlete I'm talking
about right his mindset he's a climber a
Thai masseuse yeah
there's two things that double throttle
dick job crazy stresses we circumcising
into twist
look at that hand don't wanna see him at
the glory hole yeah he's a problem and
it's no I think Alex Honnold is a
monster I think it's cool it's not the
most impressive thing of all time to be
not right I think he's a [ __ ] Savage
yeah I don't I don't you know cool it's
climbing bro we brought we made stairs
there's so many things that you don't
even need to do it anymore like that's
what I don't get
now it's like it's being the best at
drinking water out of a river it's like
now we have a faucet so you don't got to
be the best at that that's literally how
I feel about that like there are other
games we've evolved past this back in a
day when we were in the and earth all's
and [ __ ] and you could run up the ballin
dude dude a man Brian I think like
anything else is just so much technique
say what so much technique and so much
leave a lot of reps yeah rock climbing
is about doing it I think we're over
we're over doing this a little bit it's
just climbing right yeah it's like
remember when we were kids the first
thing you could do before anything else
do it you have to be that's athletic
thing you've seen sports I might be a
porn thing like I don't know how there's
this comic biggest suckers own dick Matt
Broussard do you know that kid no I've
heard anything really this guy said he
could suck his own and showed us like
above the pants like that he could get
his mouth or he guys him out there and
we're like dude how was it he goes we
tell you something it's a lot more like
sucking a dick than it is getting your
dick is he missing a river of whites
just flexible no he's just gay oh yeah
no no but didn't Marilyn Manson take out
his rib so you suck his dick great
that's her root the hairless thing is
that we [ __ ] bought it all I was in
high school I was like there was always
my solid you can find it still of Ron
Jeremy stuck in his own day
I don't think so no he's got five yeah
but big David bring that up some walkins
of black dudes where they would use
their dick as like a Mike to talk into
and today
they could have had dicks they couldn't
wait a minute hold on hold on oh my boy
Lord speaker had the biggest dick he was
a bad [ __ ] there you go
Oh ron jeremy suck in his own thing wait
go to it a lovely good oh he's doing
work - he's cradling the balls oh wow
that [ __ ] looks too lonely bro
no the longest one only charge and
scroll out no [ __ ] goes alone reasons.i
down that's how you got to do it that's
how you got to do it bro Wow yeah [ __ ]
your mouth like that damn he's
disgusting does that it's in the top
that's why Jeremy had a piece on though
he did well yeah oh no look take chance
on it go to the black and white one had
sex with a lot of pretty girls dared see
that's him rocked and look at him he can
bite the tip yeah that's amazing at no
idea I didn't know people could do that
oh yeah because here's the thing you
don't the biggest especially for like
his size like he was like from Queens
look at that [ __ ]
yeah I didn't know I didn't know guys
don't a guy that won the word worth the
word there you go right there there you
go bring that up back at him what are
you doing he looks great dummy that's a
terrible picture yes but he still
[ __ ] dude he looks like Jasmine's
father you know it hangs at the concert
he used to be at the combo that one
that's often the live one definitely
cartoon that's the Sultan yeah this is a
salt and sucking his own dick he was a
comedy store all the time
what happened he's a big fan of comedy
what's he doing these days
like what's what is he set is wrong
Jimmy snide aw I really he's got a lot
of money and he's super frugal so he
said yeah I don't know if he said to
that somewhere in sweatpants no he where
he walks with a bags but he apparently
is smell like [ __ ] smell oh yeah dinky
yai dude look at that well I think you
don't think oh yeah there's no mana yeah
porn porn does it end well for a me but
that movie doesn't end well for you know
it doesn't no it [ __ ] doesn't jenna
jameson oh my god he looks like [ __ ]
yeah that's a wrap things didn't work
out but here's the thing he bright still
has that appetite for girls ain't come
around anymore
yeah how old is he I'm getting sad 70s
how old is he 7 oh man you have any fine
man do you remember when he was on that
reality show uh which one the way each
one they're all in the house yeah yeah
later Flav him
Oh Bridget Neal's in labor start [ __ ]
bridges now 66 come on
he's agent Shetty man damn what's he do
Chi that's a funny prank I can quote his
IMDB hold on your black friend did the
prank where he held his dick up against
not a prank you just a [ __ ] the mic
but that's white boy humor man that's
like I was funny
Horace Vickers was played in the NFL for
how long I don't know wow but giant dick
oh I'm like I saw the biggest decks did
when you were it was the full football
decks of the Vegas yeah really I mean
these taxes boys advanced Joseph had the
longest acuity in your life saw ah it's
just massive
Micah long man long like what do you
mean like like elephant trunk like a
nice car
really and purple that's not my show not
like well like a brown like a purple you
know what I'd be doing homework in I
have this dick on my shoulder
damn it but why not to go to boarding
schools here okay old seas and movies my
family away he's in a bunch of movies
times of Jeff producer yeah you had tiny
little parts in those bikini Valley
carwash what's the point of boarding
school
well my parent family was in Saudi
Arabia don't live youth go away that the
schools didn't go up they didn't have
high school you grew up in Saudi Arabia
and all over the world Philippines India
Greece Saudi Arabia Lebanon Pakistan the
parents engineers associate my dad was a
banker and property GI what were you
saying what would you say in drew don't
talk about my dad being deep state cuz I
get I'll get a bunch of people go you
[ __ ] chill yeah you ever mention
alright dudes all right yeah I guess so
really interesting the minute I say
anything that maybe maybe Jeffrey
Epstein didn't kill himself
I mean maybe Jerry I've seen did kill
himself you [ __ ] go no shame on Jude
the Clintons are my dad I don't like the
Clinton my dad stay with me right now
and we I went hey Dad just bright and we
were like watching TV I go oh I haven't
asked about how about stayin man crazy
honey is he crazy killed himself and I
was like my dad argues Maryland I want
to do a thing I really don't know my
fact I know what I've heard my friends
say I let you think [ __ ] it that's our
guy that way you think and he goes well
then everyone knows he'd kill him some
point I don't know a man I think he was
working for the government and oh dude
my dad or the Mossad or something I
don't have my facts ready to go I got
eaten alive why would he say what was
the art they were just how stupid the
conspiracies are and I could kill
himself and then then I heard
rough-looking say in the greenroom it
comes to go they don't really know how
he got his money and then so I'll
download some of that stuff that'll just
say it and then I explained how you guys
mind my [ __ ] excuse me how do you use
money and my dad knew my dad no no no
but he didn't he's running from one guy
I did by he I'd buy that house a $10
meta headphone guy that's why there's a
lot of fishes they doing that they gave
him that house yeah okay so one guy the
guy who owns Victoria's Secrets name is
Leslie Iwerks Wexler
so when he's gay but there's a lot of
[ __ ] fishy [ __ ] that what goes on
there's my feeling miss my feeling is if
I was Jeffrey Epstein I would kill
myself why what it why wouldn't you kill
yourself you don't have a lot out
sniffling its but still it's still you
can't you're going to jail you're gonna
get me [ __ ] I think you'll get fuss
that's under you're not gonna put it
over your eye they never get my please
go to public they already gave him one
he's going yeah and that's why they
wouldn't give him a second one that I
made and not only that he's going to
jail where it's dangerous he can't go
out where his dangerous life's over kill
yourself he knows for me the fact that
he killed that makes total even if they
did give up lead you only got out you
don't think the cleanse would sniff him
out oh I just think he wouldn't be able
to go anywhere well I think it's above
the jobs people put all this like they
give the cleanse all this behind the
clinics have any power any more [ __ ]
power there's at once they're all pawns
it's like you're so bigger they're
billionaires that run all this [ __ ] and
the fact that nobody cares anymore like
the fact it like we really don't care
we're bringing up now do you care we
can't no they murdered a guy I don't
care had a child sex ring let me check
don't we don't care anymore and that's
why they get away with it they don't
give up once most of it but that that's
what they put out one chicken sandwich
and we forgot all about it it was how
you can pop Isis be on top I hi pop eyes
[ __ ] trumped Epstein they did child
dude they Charlie trapped Epstein they
Trump mass shootings do you know Andrew
Schultz droppings have you had it dude
it is worth forgetting about Epstein you
guys serious yes did you like
chick-fil-a before yeah the chaplains
cool all right yeah but it's a chick I
think like we over eight southern food
like southern people get so excited
about their food it's just like it's
just [ __ ] well sweet tea is just
[ __ ] tea with sugar like get over it
yeah like it's not a chicken sandwich
this is chicken and on with bread yeah
but this Popeyes one it is better it is
noticeably barb as a second for a food
that I've ever had right your brothers
know it is legit dude and we had to go
to two different places in Chicago to
find it because it was sold out you
can't get in anyway no we had to go to
this morning Chino
don't do it they don't do it's not worth
it just wait get chef together go we'll
be there oh but it's legit but that's
all it took it took one chicken craze
and we forgot all I forgot everything
it's all I see that's pickles you don't
even care about I've seen no cat but you
were gonna bring him to the finest pie
of some kind was into young girls
typically what from 14 is 17 or
something yeah I had a lot of money I
think he didn't have any money
nobody well it's alessa's money yeah I
think he was probably I what the most
about the island I see when he bring
like big big leaguers I see both in
flats what I to his Island yes you'd
they said he would hire these I mean not
we'd be fun a lot of my modest girls
yeah but some of them they say they're
20 but they're younger and they film
everything I do do on purpose the
enemies I met you got if you're got hurt
on these money trap honey it's like he
got this free crib in New York just like
50 million dollar crib to happen a vault
is recording equipment in it
now I'm no conspiracy theorist I really
don't give up enough of a [ __ ] but if
you get a free crib with tons of like
CIA level recording equipment and then
you gonna have parties at your crib with
these girls
and let me tell you something none of us
have been at a party where we've ID'd
the girl we were talking to the
assumption at a party is well if you're
here you must be legit old enough to
[ __ ] legit why would you be it exactly
my mom would invite a young girl I went
to that mansion heated by yes he was
enjoying life yes I know who Tommy you
need to tell me I can tell you he's not
my friend
no I can tell you I think I think it's
Eric once and he'll tell a story I mean
I'm sure on Rogan yeah but so he's a
scientist and a very famous scientist he
one thing he said about Epstein I know
that guy yeah moles Epstein was super
smart and really knew his math and
science yeah and then he noticed a
camera in the [ __ ] sorry Eric he's
gonna kill me but he notices a camera
and he goes he knows that I know that
there's a camera there so this is where
he said to his wife so what is his
goodbyes [ __ ] and his wife says his
wife said you're a you are a [ __ ] he
notices [ __ ] like Peter Thiel is your
daddy say whatever he tells him freedom
ideas are so important as long as
they're my ideas
whatever you say Peter you don't think
is curious they all got the same exact
agenda no that's freedom of ideas a
planet no you hired a smart guys to say
message oh listen to his [ __ ] podcast
I've met him I've sat down him I talk to
him yeah he's not [ __ ] smart guys not
Peter tails [ __ ] trust me on that oh
he's absolutely
Peter Thiel's daddy hundred percent
Peter Thiel is uh that's daddy right
there I'm [ __ ] I see yeah well
he started PayPal with you on Moscow
that's how he's a massive tech guy he's
on the spectrum he also got so easy
he's a genius Neil's a genius yeah but
he's a big tech guy he you know investor
in all the early stuff and he's the one
did got Gawker out of here he bankrolled
Hogan Hulk Hogan said because Gawker
outed him when he back in a day and he
had that vendetta Dan locally I respect
how he like held on to that [ __ ] like a
function notation and weight and like
waited 15 years that's every Monday Jim
kung fu movie with him I had dinner with
which one Peter teal exact said now I
wanna hear I was sitting across from him
and I'm gonna tell you this you know
I'll talk and I and what I do is I go oh
I read this and I put a bunch of [ __ ]
together I'm basically parroting should
I saw hug that's all I don't have
original thoughts I'm a [ __ ] I'm a
loudmouth
this dude
now this guy's my age this [ __ ]
it opens it up and and come out and talk
about the Clintons mm-hm or talk about
some [ __ ] yes and fire bro
he'd say [ __ ] here we go you go heat I
never even thought of that angle he was
such it where do you hear him speak at I
was at dinner would you do like a
podcast or anything no my buddy invited
me to dinner is house a small time he's
worth like nine billion this is you know
this is a real power broker do this
there's a few people world that makes
[ __ ] happen this [ __ ] is one of
them when he talks dude though he said
he he said [ __ ] you never even thought
of he's such a unique original thing
these guys are trying to live forever
these are the dudes who want to go to
Mars and [ __ ] like like every you know
every movie comes out is now about like
taking human consciousness and like
using our bodies as sleeves and then
like hook it in some we could put in a
computer put another vessel for this is
what these [ __ ] been working on
forever yeah out of here like this idea
that they're having one life forget
about it if you see it in a movie that
means they've been working on for 20
years he plays he plays chess and
apparently there's a legend I don't know
I heard the story I heard that he was
playing Kasparov the greatest chess
player of all time body doesn't he lost
and he goes like this he doesn't walk
and he got really mad and Kasparov goes
where you're a sore loser and he goes
find me a good loser I'll find you a
loser yes I love it
like Peter Thiel's no joke which is back
to original from he's American yeah yeah
really interesting guy they don't play
there's a few DS [ __ ] out there
that really make the world move he's the
real deal and if they need some well I
don't know if he had anything to do with
it but like the people that need people
killed they just get him killed bro
Epstein bodied done I don't have to kill
you anymore taking your reputation
Germany originally is he is born and
raised in West Germany damn but that's
back in a day he speaks English fluently
that's crazy women you know and that's
not a thing how dope is America we just
steal all the [ __ ] smart people like
Elon Musk got like a few good ideas in
South Africa and they were like all
right buddy just one of your diamonds
get the yeah here you should hear
Weinstein talk about like yeah that
subject and the jay-z say I'll let you
why the Chinese are trying to Bobby will
sit down have a real meal with that dude
well Brian hates training go play your
[ __ ] minds
the Chinese Brian a Chinese language
it's a city like the character Chinese
Ryan had one dinner with wine steaming
came back here was like the Chinese no
this is how suicide bombers happen right
it's just here's a bunch of information
it's like [ __ ] it strap me I'm like a
vessel put those ideas in my head now
just act on her what do you want me to
do think for myself [ __ ] off master
maybe he's only worth 2.5 billion they
don't believe that [ __ ] don't believe
that [ __ ] bro
well then eat [ __ ] compared to like Bill
Gates it's not even like it's like 2,500
million don't even worry about that [ __ ]
the the influence you have when you're
like a tech 2.5 billion is data the
whole game is data now right if you have
data you control the world you know how
people act you know how to rig the
system like that's why Facebook I think
of it Zuckerberg yeah this [ __ ]
knows everything he knows everything
about us how to target anybody who wants
how to put ideas there that's why the
government's got to step in every once
in while I'm back yo yo yo yo dead that
here's the thing on Zuckerberg so rich
right Abdulla girl son I think I think
he's shadow banned me for saying that
bro oh [ __ ] oh I don't care about these
good yeah well no Instagram all they own
it they own Instagram da I guess I don't
have the same like most billing it's not
that she's ugly but it's for yeah yeah
it's it's he came in early I respect it
ugly he stay with her she stay with her
IntelliJ did you know that she's Chinese
protego they got married um she's pretty
she's not bad nah she cool chic
old-school I mean he's not exactly
hey bro billion dollars looks pretty
sexy hey what did jay-z say I never seen
another glee billionaire on cue and
jay-z's of jay-z looks like jay-z jay-z
no camel babies who neighs beetle play
what you met it right no no never met
Jay he never did the show never did the
show I'm nervous
has he has Jay even done breakfast cook
I would not I would yes he has ah yes
yes Wow
yes yes but not in a while but he asked
on Jay Z joining up with the NFL I love
it what's he love exactly do do you J
like me your money
what's because ran the whole Kaepernick
in the whole black movement thing and
you know and oppression against black
people so cabinet was taken a knee which
like moved on way beyond that he was
taking me for police brutality not for
the NFL's role and then it looked like
he was getting blackballed by the NFL so
those things get conflated by many
people but and then oh but now it's hey
captain I should have a job right it's
like this isn't fair you should have a
job and jay-z's in Jays egos hopefully
we can get Kaepernick IRA it's like wow
this whole thing didn't start for
Kaepernick Davidge job that you guys are
losing the rights in it also the reason
why he doesn't have a job maybe 10% cuz
the kneeling thing because he didn't
want backlash 90% of his he's just not
very good right and then people bring up
the argument not very good they'll bring
up the argument like he's better than
like the backup quarterbacks that are in
the NFL and he probably is right maybe
that's debatable and and maybe that's
available as good as some of them sure
but they're going he's not essential
well no it's not a starter so the NFL
teams if I'm a billionaire owner for the
let's say this angular is I'm gonna go
hold on I could sign this young kid who
no one really gives a [ __ ] about no
one's can really I can create need
animosity in the locker room anything or
I can sign Kaepernick who isn't gonna
play yet there's so much demand for
exactly people in be pissed I'm not
gonna sign a fool yeah so I'm gonna sign
a plate away yeah who's gonna like no
Asian yeah like why would you why would
you sign up back
that creates division like I'll sign Tom
Brady if he creates division I don't
give a [ __ ] cuz it's Tom Brady Yeah
right this is the best quarterback you
guys want talk [ __ ] he's gonna win game
that's it same thing with Tim Tebow
he was just as good as a lot of the
other backup quarterbacks but all the
front office's went dude as soon as our
starters those intercepts right this
crowd is so Pro Tebow right he sells so
many jerseys it's gonna distract from
what we're trying to do yeah I don't
want to a shot I think the biggest is
shopper next with jay-z is he's divisive
but he goes out well he did take him to
the AFC Championship game and the Super
Ball that will hold up that was long a
long time ago then then I fell went
running quarterback they always figure
him out unless you're Michael Vick
running quarterback he if we get him
outside the pocket is actually terrible
so we're just gonna reinforce him to
stay in the pocket rattles cage and he's
not very good so the NFL figured him out
and then this happened huh but it was
[ __ ] that's not anything the jay-z
things a little different right so it's
like he's still doing the know your
Rights Campaign Kaepernick still doing
it killing it with that easy killing it
though what's last under-cabinet talked
about it well Kaepernick doesn't talk
that's the problem
Cabarete doesn't talk and yeah and that
hurts him that actually doesn't talk you
haven't addressed the media and has like
a 20 million dollar contract from Nike
so when people go look what he
sacrificed 'add made money made more
money look what he sacrificed right
we'll hold on if he didn't do this
he'd be out of the NFL just because his
skill set right and he and he would have
no Nike deal so here's so here's the
argument right he was raised by white
parents right yeah opted but here's the
here's the argument that I find puzzling
right bring it's like so Kaepernick is
like hey we need to all come together to
stop the NFL from boycotting me so I can
play in the NFL again right and that
will be a victory so you want to play in
the NFL again you want to get paid by
the NFL but if jay-z gets paid by the
NFL somehow he's a sellout
yeah you can't he can't be a sellout if
you are to also willing to pay by the
NFL but yeah you're also trying to be in
the club exactly so it's like that was
my that was my biggest issue with the
what the whole thing it's like like at a
certain point time and this is why the
sellout thing is the worst moniker and
it at a certain point of time in order
to have real power and influence in the
world you need to sell out a little bit
you need to sell out a little bit due to
me like like Israel sells weapons to
Egypt they haven't had the best
relationship over the years but they
realize hey we are gonna make [ __ ]
power moves and we're gonna be a player
you gotta have a seat at the [ __ ]
table sacrifice a little have a seat at
the table that's just what it is if you
want and jay-z understands the long game
and jay-z understands listen
[ __ ] if I'm a part owner of a
team I guess you I can hire I can hire
more black people to be influential in
this game but if you don't even let me
[ __ ] on the team then we're just gonna
be sitting here complaining all great
here's everything here's the other thing
why it's great to have jay-z involved in
Mark Cuban said this and it's nothing
anyone's like oh my god that's that's a
groundbreaking but Mark Cuban goes the
NFL's problem ID numbers are down and
like you know their social media is not
doing that well numbers came back up
well little bit we'll see how it goes
well the season starts Thursday yeah
well last season I thought numbers came
back and they're coming but so Mark
Cuban goes one the reasons why they're
behind the NBA and stuff like that he
goes cuz the NFL if you pay attention is
always about the NFL shield the NBA is
about players yeah look at the logo
Jerry West it's a player they
everything's about the players up the
promotions about the players the NFL the
promotion is about the team's the
Patriots the shield so they don't they
they never ever focus on the shield the
NFL the shield you know that like [ __ ]
that that got logo so the NFL is only
about the NFL the NBA is only ran by the
Players Association you're guaranteed
money baseball - it's about the players
even though they don't have a lot of
personalities but in the NBA they I'm
speaking English yeah that's Alex
Honnold but but with the NBA's it's
blowing up because there's so many stars
and you know the personalities their
signature shoes the animal hats who blow
the whole global sport but but I'll deal
but it's huge deal but the NFL has
someone
great personalities but they don't allow
these guys to do any of them yeah
there's you know they look like they're
I helmets yeah that's a visual factors
think about how massive that is right so
this happened to me once I'm walking
down my street and I see this guy
pulling into a parking lot right the guy
looks exactly
Darrelle Revis was a cornerback for the
Jets paid a lot of money okay a lot of
money
he's wearing Darrelle Revis is number on
a Jets t-shirt okay I'm looking inside
his expedition or whatever car was I
think it was expedition he's looks like
Darrelle Revis he's got a green Jets
practice shirt that has drawer uses
number on it now I want to go up to them
and I want to go to hell Revis if I'm
wrong you're right the cost is heavy
happy right I got to just walk up that
hosing cons pros and cons I get a selfie
con I'm ready Rose I just go you are who
you are cons I'm a big just go Revis
yeah yeah yeah but the fact is we don't
know what they look like so much because
they got the helmet on why do you think
Odell Beckham jr. dyed his hair blond
yeah differentiate Odell Beckham's wrong
he's always out he's helmets always off
that can he's off the field my helmet
off he's landing helmets off he's the
also the only NFL player with a
signature shoe boom twenty million
dollars damn the only staff outlet and
check out his Calvin Klein campaign too
he's counting Klein Odell Beckham oh
yeah monster take a look at it great Bob
yeah it's a great Bob rate by the way
and by the way yeah he's 511 I looked
his visor oh okay okay great bod hell of
a body look at the BOD he's probably the
most fit I mean besides Tom Brady Fred
the most famous amongst like 18 to 36
males
I mean he's especially not being a
quarterback he's big think about that
you touch the ball eight times a game
max use your super officer he's a star
for the New York Giants yeah biggest
teams let's cowboys and a useless
position wide receiver useless I was the
Asian guy over there completely useless
interesting I'm all the NFL is past name
on the backs you name one name one elite
wide receiver in the last 20 years that
is one in championship it is a useless
overpaid position that's why the patrons
keep winning cuz they know now I mean
name one maybe one elite wide receiver
well no quarterback quarterbacks by far
the most important no but I mean by far
if we have a good deep name is why
receiver just an elite wide receiver in
last year's right
Jerry was Jerry win one last week Randy
never won one rent but what go through
all the elite Calvin Johnson nope
not Randy I play of Chado just single
know if it's Julie Larry Fitz window
it's his name played for San Francisco
49ers Terrell Owens won keep going it is
the deep a wide receiver
let me is the worst invariably do the
Patriots were winning Super Bowl Plaxico
Burress Plaxico Burress overs one one
for the Giants and he was instrumental
elite point he's not elite dude Patriots
they had Mexican guys and Jewish guys
went in as their little white dice put a
five foot six knows if the position the
marginal gain you get from paying an
elite wide receiver so does a super
she's you go to super all just go list
of super ball I'm telling you you won't
find it you just think of any elite wide
receiver they'll never win because they
take up so much sour crap and they don't
affect the game enough divas what about
you know in effect the guy wrote the
book kid just give me the damn ball
what's his name um are you going - back
to drones yeah no no no um just give me
the damn ball Michael Irvin
no Michael everyone that's what that's
back in a day wait no there's another
one also head what the [ __ ] is his name
the guy Roy just give me the damn ball
he was like hold on let me go hold on
Shin go to so past twenty years what
you're wearing to that so I'd be
throughout nine you want to say yeah go
to nine maybe maybe it's a little after
that but the nine Pittsburgh Steelers
Hines Ward nope he's not Ali not at all
New York Giants after that my Colts got
Marvin Harrison
Marvin one and do you know the score
that game it was like twelve eight or so
they barely won that game thirty years
they want some you're saying an elite
wide receiver is not waste it's not
worth paying because they can't affect
the game at all they don't affect the
game defensively at all they can only
affect the game when they get the ball
they get the ball at max eight times a
game well that's if you're super if you
so no defenses take away but talk to me
start talk to me right so you have now
we're talking so the the defense has
seen so let's say you're playing Odell
Beckham jr. right you're gonna make sure
he doesn't pop off you listen he's not
gonna get his these other guys have to
be this if you have an elite cornerback
you cut off this is this is how you
defend with an elite cornerback if you
have Deion Sanders or one of these guys
this is your defense yo Deion you got
that whole half of the field he goes
yeah I got it he said it's over he's a
rare one but yeah all those guys they're
just he was a scheme can they can create
it so he doesn't get here but but
doesn't he he might make some plays but
he's not going to modify any Mostow can
be a pain in the ass and take the
defense in one direction right I mean
they can be add there if you have an
elite elite corner yeah that's a wash
its am telling you and that's why you
pay the elite elite corners that much
it's like it's like a pitcher right like
you know these pitchers get paid you
know tons of money in the and in Major
League Baseball
it's like yeah because that game is a
guaranteed dub yes like you give me
three runs and we're winning I might
even ask you for a lot you gave me three
runs my ear is 2.1 so that means if you
give me three will win in a game okay
you know what's going on with the Zika
Elliott right now oh yeah you're
supposed to sign any day now but they
said they opted they did offer him like
the biggest contract and running back
history he's like nope I want even more
heroes I want more but I want guaranteed
more yeah
guaranteed money because now in with
running backs you like this span like
four years maybe and where it's a little
dicey but not and they're gonna sign I
think any day now don't think I wouldn't
do is running back dime-a-dozen I know
you Cowboys are gonna do it at least
they say it's gonna change the game for
certain position especially running back
he's going there to know no matter what
your pay me yes I got four years maybe
he might say another two running backs
time it does it you could find go to 1
oak whoever is the bouncer at the front
door
just get him that is your wide receiver
or running back guaranteed you don't
need to pay them because they don't
produce [ __ ] that you have invested in
the offensive line in the defensive line
and never get a common event quarterback
and drafting is huge too because think
about you have four years where you're
paying in pennies no yeah that's why
your life
Ilyn incorrect everybody's on rookie
salary you pay him nothing you but
here's what's crazy to me and that's why
I think quarterback might be the
toughest job in professional sports
think how many guys they draft and none
of them ever work out ever it's not so
you're starting so rare that that guy
becomes successful and then as you need
so many guys to protect them like and
they have to be so look at Andrew Luck
getting smart they got to be smart even
if you're smart have all the skills have
a great arm and have wide receivers
Andrew Luck
Andrew Luck check check check but no
offensive line my body physically cannot
come back did you guys see Gronkowski
who retired I was like what is retired
do you hear him talking to them what was
he saying scribe what do you say to how
tough it like he's like I didn't want to
do anymore man he starts crying bring
that up chin I'm saying Kraske you watch
cuz he's such a bro
yeah like God get the fight when you
watch this like I get it man like he
gets emotional how he was you know I
wanted to play but like my body and I
mentally and you can't help there is it
it the top a minute long yeah yes all
right still a bonus Patriots fans I love
all my fans I love Patriots fans and
wherever I go your fans the CBD oil
somebody gets sucked my gosh where am i
coming back I'm walking across the
stream like you're walking because
you're coming back it's crazy I
understand I I feel that love but I want
to be clear to my fans I needed to
recover I was not in a good place
football was bringing me down and I
didn't like it and I was losing that joy
and money like the joy I'm sorry bright
man but oh let me oh I really was and I
was fighting through it and I knew what
I signed up for and I knew what I was
fighting through and I knew I just have
to fix myself and I believe I have the
tools I have the people around me I have
CB Denton CBD medic team around me now
to help me to deal with my pain whenever
I need it when I'm during a workout
whatever it is so I can do the most safe
alternative way for myself I believe I
have great people around me to get to
I need to get to in life and I am very
satisfied where I am in life now I mean
spare well you can argue with that guy
oh you just keep getting injured your
heads all [ __ ] up my mind but my one
of my best friends but I remember he was
again I think I'm done you're like what
the [ __ ] I like done you you're killing
it me anything I'm sick of playing -
whoo-hoo - stuff yeah good buddy well
his injury Steinbeck and who's a tight
end for the for the Rams and then
finished with the bills super Superman
really graphing a sec around my room oh
yeah one my room I've never seen often
like blonde guy I won five out of my
[ __ ] life rewrite better than
Gronkowski I mean it's play oh what
right he was not better play better body
better body I don't know he's bodied up
I mean he's just something I'd love to
know more than anyone better than it
looks like Superman it's just hilarious
there's three of us at the be him right
there four right oh it's 265 pounds eats
like [ __ ] to shred city you know he's
that's like JD a freak right there was
always vertical what was this vertical
like if some crazy a to somewhere around
a 4 6 in the 40 yeah yeah he's he's in
absurdly yeah that's that's game over
various I just real estate man he's
killing it so do you think Gronk was
talking about mental stuff
yeah like yes CT damage that I think it
was a number of things he's that is
sheriff concuss have you dealt with any
that [ __ ] do you have any like
concussion stuff made me funny dude I
did I was watching some club I didn't
know that you knocked out croquet and
watch that fight sometimes watch it from
start to finish
dude I'm okay it's definitely gonna kick
in any day now so bro are you or seeming
while you can't I just got it punched
full-on Broca's nose knee like this
Brennan looks attack Congress what are
you worried about it oh yeah really sure
I mean that's why that's all um but you
know what's how many concussions yet I
have no idea I'm at three minimum
between football and then just on record
from my knockouts and you and I won I
got concussed so I don't know dude I
don't know ten I would say
fifteen to 20 Oh watch out white with
kids that's not okay here's the thing
some people some people get them you
know they have a ton of them in the it's
a certain gene okay where you're more
prone to suffer from gotcha and I've had
the test and I don't have that you'll
see you good I'm good yeah we'll see I
mean look it might not be the best
possible situation but you're not gonna
go mental
it's like you know some people they can
do a psychedelic trip I think I think
Brett amuses his brain so often I really
think that also has a factor keep it
busy he does he never you're always
working out also you see now I don't
know when the way you take care of
yourself I'll be the first person to
shoot up your own theater is very
strange hey be when you're selling stuff
online like we are like defect a merge
yeah
they need their stuff they need it fast
so I told Jay what yo bro how are people
human stuff so fast not time it's so
impression shipstation calm you're right
what he said that he said everybody
needs shipstation calm is the fastest
easiest most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders so it's like a
regular company that ships things
overnight and stuff but this is a new
competitor basically yeah I love your
energy shift station helps you get
orders out quickly saves money on
shipping costs and you keep your
customers happy no matter where you're
selling Amazon Etsy your own website
like tea fat k ship station brings you
all your orders into one simple
interface makes it really easy carriers
even on your phone man
yep you SPE USPS FedEx UPS even Amazon
Fulfillment so
you can compare and choose the best
shipping solution for you and your
customer no wonder shipstation is the
number one choice of online sellers just
ship more and less time with the best
rates period right now the tea fat k
listeners and viewers ship station you
can try it for free for 60 days and use
the promo Mo's fighter there's
absolutely no risk you can start your
free trial without even entering your
credit card info just visit ship station
calm click on the microphone at the top
of the home page type in fighter that
ship station comm enter promo code
fighter ship station comm make ship
happen o bigger light this weekend bro
yes would you talk about it when you
audio we should be talking to fight do
exhaustion poor a could be you know what
we're doing for it he's gonna fight
companion you know what someone else can
do for it watch it make pain makes a
lake if you think you know your fighters
make some bank with draftkings
draftkings and also if you're like well
i don't like fighting it's good island
for me
you can bet I know who that was you can
bet on football because the NFL starts
this Thursday it's gonna be on Sunday
but there's also college football
whatever you want to do whatever you
want to bet on go to draftkings.com
khabib who do you have for that fight
are you allowed to say right now though
no I'm not not on here dude alright but
you can join draftkings and just pick
six fighters stay under the salary cap
and pile up the points for advances
takedowns and more there's no better way
to put your MMA knowledge to the test
than with draftkings I'm gonna get
involved in this do it dude plus all new
and existing users can get a deposit
bonus up to $500 makes fight night more
exciting yes all you got to do is
download the app or go to draftkings.com
right now use promo codes fighter at the
sign up and compete for over two hundred
thousand dollars in prizes and don't
forget all new and existing users can
get a deposit bonus of $500 that's promo
code fighter at signup claim your
deposit bonus up to $500 only at
draftkings
minimum $5 deposit credit positive bonus
requires 25 playthrough
restrictions apply CDIP knock on details
so I'm des morning Kevin Hart was in a
terrible car accident his car actually
swerved off the road somebody else was
driving on Mulholland and he fell down
an embankment him the driver and there
was a woman in the back they're all ok
the woman didn't need to be hospitalized
there was a car with some people from
Kevin's team following his car that fell
off they actually drove him home and
later took him to the hospital
so I go down Mulholland all the time you
know Mahon was built the guy Mulholland
who develop Mahon was built for racing
so like James Dean you stole he's raced
down there these two have real races
down there so like real car enthusiasts
will drive down Mulholland race but it's
it's a part of a race it's like was make
because there's so much traffic hauling
that so much money went I want a spot
where me and my boys can go with our
race cars in the city and drive damn it
yeah so that that's one of the reason
Mulholland was built yeah so oh boy I
mean you didn't get going really fast
and there's turns and like you better
know your [ __ ] also that wasn't much of
Barracuda but it's also a restored
Barracuda so I'm sure it had like
new-age suspension and airbags
everything but still nothing probably
had 707 horsepower rear-wheel drive also
I don't think it had them did it have
one of these for whiplash you didn't
have don't go address see there let me
see the seat zoom in on that seat
oh you think if there's no head that'll
[ __ ] you up which major major back
issues you had major back surgery which
was successful thank God dude my brother
text me I was on the plane with Derek
Derek posts and my my feature who just
quit the Comi store cuz he's bawling a
comedy now shoutout dick post and he I
got a text somewhere on the plane and he
started comedy because he saw Kevin
Hart's first special he's like oh I want
to do that
yeah and I got takes with my brother my
plane goes holy [ __ ] you hear about
Kevin Hart I was like no I just and I
get a thing that goes Kevin Hart car
crash I thought oh [ __ ]
Kevin died I'd be certain I show it to
Derek dude you got a motion oh man
cuz I couldn't click on the link he
sighs and I go I went not do I was
and choked up on no way he died my
brother goes no just backs bro he's
gonna be fine let's go wha do you know
do you know if you ever met Kevin Kevin
Hart no yes but not like such a good guy
was so candid [ __ ] guy yeah he's so
funny
yeah so cool yeah now that that is an
addict man yeah but he'll be all right
thank God [ __ ] could have been so bad
yeah it's such a bummer but also it's
like keV what do you do and do Barracuda
driving up you drive pretty crazy man
Hydra you know me I drug crazy yeah that
fry has more horsepower on that thing I
Drive crazy I was in Italy all right
yeah what do you get out of that drive
him crazy what's like the listen late at
night down the hall and I get it getting
late at night with dem Mahal in yeah and
like Laurel Canyon it's just like that's
where I can open up my call or the
threes and I have it and it sticks to
the [ __ ] road like a frog and it's
just great I was some windows down some
classic rock I'm with Jimmy Berkman like
you know yeah but like what happens like
what does it make you do you like what
just makes me happy heart gets going no
it doesn't get my heart rate up I just
enjoy driving fast in a fast car right
right yeah I had a friend from our this
guy was scratched so fast I was like oh
it's a matter of time you're driving so
fast I said don't you have to slow down
we're any delay you have to slow down
and Jimmy goes dude I was literally
thinking to myself I'm gonna die cuz we
were going 120 miles an hour
so he goes okay okay so I made him stop
slow down we get in we hang out all
night
we get into the car I get it I squeeze
him with a bunch of girls and Jimmy's
sitting here he puts a seatbelt on put
this same driver and I'm sitting on a
girl and a guy's lap but we're still
eating like that I'm like this and I go
you know what that is very dangerous
this [ __ ] guy drives fast wait I stop
where I get out I get in another car
with a bunch of people I don't know I
put my seatbelt on long story short
this guy runs into a tree there's no
tree at 60 miles an hour Jimmy can move
his shoulder he's like this he was
trying to hold the girl the girl hit
them things so hard she was out complete
Jesus Christ out completely my friend
broke his leg and his ankle on his foot
Fox say yeah thank God he gets out of
car he throws up but at this [ __ ] I
never spoke to him again cuz this
[ __ ] drives like that let me
some was the driver Chinese no shoot he
was Italian she the girl on the front
seat she was knocked out even though
there were a seat belts yeah knocked out
so I saw this and when we pulled up this
is your fault
oh my cuz you say Bergen knew he was
sucked at driving and if you know you
would have said hey stop driving so far
I know this because I had no seatbelt I
was yeah here you back I don't have a
seat put on slow the bar may be on
Psychopaths doesn't kill him like
shuttle bus right oh god that's right
and when I saw Jimmy when I pulled up
and I saw Jimmy he was standing like
this he was frozen because he didn't
know it was hurting I thought he was
dead
I remember gone oh that's my boy but a
little part of you was like I told you
but I'm I knew I shouldn't be in that
phone's bar with camera the girl came to
I was like yeah then we got a [ __ ]
house made out with her I can't remember
anything we used to love sucking my dick
no no that was my house my [ __ ] dad
we were in Sicily my father this whole
family had been killed and one that the
family members are there the whole
family and know my dad my grandfather
the most tactless person here I'm an
Italian talking about what happened my
father's there I remember I never forget
this as a kid mangas and what happened
was they're driving and the truck came
here and as the drive and the truck hits
and just completely and the [ __ ]
mother and the they start to cry at the
table and my father goes dumb you got to
stop here you're showing us with
silverware what happened and the bucket
it's been a weally Oh Mike about
tackling Caesar I'll never forget that
as a kid my father told me gave me a
lesson on what's called task men and he
explained it to me well she gets in you
go thank God kids memories a minute
so a pregnant woman was in a Denver jail
and she gave birth by herself shut up at
Denver
she's currently suing the jail because
there were a couple nurses and guards
there she told hey I'm having
contractions throughout the day they
sited to wait and see what would happen
hmm it's protocol in that jail that it's
up to the nurse to decide whether or not
to take the pregnant woman to the
hospital based off of how her
contractions are going
the nurses decided to wait and to see if
she was actually going to give birth
soon and she ended up giving birth in
her jail cell by herself and nobody came
to help her for five hours
damn even after the baby what a bunch of
morons I can't believe how I should do
but are the people that work at jails
sometimes another look the suicide watch
guy for epsilon whatever I get it yes
yes yes here's my question
have you guys have a squatty potty
before your if you review squatty potty
to take a [ __ ] oh yeah you mean just
squatting down no no there's a device
called a squat and I'll tell you Tizen
technique no no have you used it yeah
did it in this fine zoning out you'll
never use that goddamn yeah it's it's
I'm just so I've tried squatty potty
what it does is it lifts your legs
upright so that you're not exactly what
it is so that your intestines are
actually more streamlined and then you
can [ __ ] easier and you [ __ ] much easier
okay you've noticed that this I grew up
overseas was I used to [ __ ] that's how
people [ __ ] right okay I'm wondering if
there's like maybe there's something
like that for pregnancy like maybe the
leaning laying down thing that is so
women so that's easier for the doctor
women typically will squat or though
about maybe she's baby spit pregnancy
wasn't that bad notice she was laying
down what she was laying down that's on
her butt I've said that's cuz it now
time you see no other choice you've been
in a room I have for both my kids being
born it's a mother [ __ ] is it I see a
woman when she goes through it's like
what cuz the laying down cuz if they
squatted with it run out it comes right
out I solve it a good way to stuff that
shirt bro in it gravity it's grass
dude I swear to God I really do it in
war better do it in water
well the ho let's do it in order man do
it in water I don't know what that does
Apocalypto and the babies born under in
the water do you think that Alex Honnold
if the baby's crowning could just take
his [ __ ] head with to his fingers
fingers it's a video of a woman giving
birth and catching it in her hand
standing up she's Asian of course and I
swear to god she just be slightly squats
scoops it out and then takes the whole
baby out it's by herself nobody else
does or says you'll find it - girl
cousin just did it on and then was like
good to go yeah [ __ ] without anything no
know them though somehow she did not
pass out she gave birth by herself women
are built for the her this her now she
got a cellie
she's good this is you get bottom bunk
but for real I I think they play the
easier way to do birth is it bad chance
it doesn't show it just kind of shows
her the moments before leading us when
she's like how okay let's do this to her
just as a human being I don't know what
she did to be in there ended up sliding
this like little like almost like a pee
pad under her cell okay they're all here
but that's like a animal pee pad yeah
what a piece of [ __ ]
what are they god dammit damn barrel
okay not a lot of urgency babe well she
is pretty this is uh cut up video she's
having a baby for Christ's sake oh you
see she's feeling it's bright things
that's insane she's feeling it there
what is wrong with these product [ __ ]
that's her like crying right like it's
coming her in the middle of contractions
just out of curiosity Jen did you find
everyone
no while we watch this I can help look
keep going it is hey way to go Denver
Jail get it together you [ __ ] guys
get it together you [ __ ] idiots
you bureaucratic dum-dums hey anybody
who likes government that's how [ __ ]
efficient government is yeah let's let's
make the government bigger in tax people
70% of their money is it you [ __ ]
socialist such ills are private and [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] that Oh Chinese woman gives
birth in the middle of the city
oh no but but this is not it but we can
always do it don't always watch that
smart oh my god she's gangster dog I
don't lay the baby hits the tarmac let's
have a baby watch out man that's better
let's move on yeah woman giving birth
standing up dude this is how you're
supposed to do it man I've really think
this laying down style you get a
c-section enough to deal with any of
that
did youdid wifey do see ya both times
well the new ones coming in November so
you got to run it back with the
c-section you can't go natural oh my
what happened you saw accident there we
go let's go
that's what I'm talkin bout that's an
that's how you give birth that's and
let's go
that's so birth I've been there I've
seen it that's birth right there that's
him breathing [ __ ] look at that baby
coming through
all right this what happens everyday
boys and girls she's the flattest ass of
all she's a bad look at that one that's
a bad oh that's so nasty that's what I'm
talking about so this woman right there
bracers [ __ ] with her glasses on still
new permanent I'm sick with their
glasses on Brian
manicure still life
playing around yeah and she's not even
she's not phased nothing she's give me
that titty girl she's a woman made for
me he is built for this
look he's so fo nice hamstring dog now
that lady knows how to birth that's how
you give birth never gave birth before
that's what else we got
[Music]
speaking of Popeyes a sues papa
yes a man is in the process of suing
Popeyes for $5,000 for false
advertisement he says that he had to
drive to multiple Popeyes only to be
turned away because they didn't have any
more chicken sandwiches he said that he
met a worker at one of his local Popeyes
that said that he would save some
chicken sandwiches and sell them for $24
each $5 for the sandwich and then the 19
for his troubles the guy paid this local
Popeyes worker 25 $25 for no $24 for the
chicken sandwich met him at the Popeyes
the following day and the guy never
showed up
yeah I can't get half that's my favorite
have the sandwich oh my mind I can't
think straight
it just consumes you that's my favorite
I can't be happy oh my God he's looking
for a 1500 you know what this is saying
that this is God I like LeBron it's hard
to stick up for him it's like LeBron
trying to trademark Taco Tuesday it was
so dumb what's next happy hour Friday
days been around forever dude in general
trademarking is so stupid like hey
LeBron throwback Thursday well the
three-peat I think that was coined by
what's-his-name the Pat who is the but
no can we acknowledge wait Jordan knows
what you're talking about
so we repeat you have Riley remember
when they were talking with a three-peat
yeah the Bulls we're gonna make a
three-peat repeat throughout I think Pat
Riley is the one who actually liked the
therapy no Jackson tell Jackson or or
Petra but just trademarking in general
like how [ __ ] dumb is this identity
[ __ ] like you could just own a saying
you can own a sound why my life like why
can you own that I don't understand that
that makes no sense it 3 feet dude Taco
Tuesday bro it's absurd that's crazy
well like so how much money do you mean
you're a billion dollar contract right
from Nike X is why do you insist Morris
this one is like business no it's him no
yeah I'm sure him on the video be like
taco cuz he keeps doing Taco Tuesday
yeah yeah he's done this so stupid but
like he has to know it's not his cuz
he's mimicking a Mexican accent when he
does it so he must know that he didn't
think of this yeah he does this
impression and then it caught on so
people like all right maybe I'll get it
but I just find it so absurd of the jut
there is IV the judge Mike what dude you
know Ohio State v Ohio State you know
the Ohio State they tried to trademark
the well I give them cuz they're V I get
the last eight and they want to sell
shirts with just the on it but it's like
are you [ __ ] [ __ ] they look that
is weird well it's like T's you know say
Miami own the you know you shouldn't be
able to own I'm alone I don't think you
should be able to own anything I mean
like language even zippers the idea of
it like you found a way to zip your
jacket right and then some guy in a
completely different country invents
another way to zip his jacket at the
same time yeah but because you
trademarked it now he is to pay a guy I
had to pay a guy a thousand dollars kind
of sunny hue trademark bryan callen calm
he owned that you know in that domain
that's a but that's different that's
like a piece of real estate on the
internet where which you want to use but
even i mean i don't want to get to like
[ __ ] annoying with it but like even
the idea that we can like own land is
really funny like someone who's just
like no that's mine private laws nor for
society let me see his video with
reversal by my fan I'm thinking about
what is it buddy this family self with
his family at we celebrate now this last
week his [ __ ] dude he's got a great
sense imagine he's on they're going eats
want on Wednesday it's a very good
Japanese accent not a chance oh yes it's
so great we put up with certain accent I
think I never understood why are certain
accents racist enchanted by an accent
for [ __ ] chicken Wednesday's the
black bag no what is it soul food
Saturday my buddy no vodka by by our
cousin fleiger - he was saying that he's
like he's like imagine you just came out
like it's so full Saturday y'all dude
don't not go over no not in today's
world not in today's world one time does
he get this is a robbery
have you guys seen this video yet love
this dude no this is insane Luis and
this this guy that's lighting up a
cigarette yeah he's in a bar where the
entire bar is getting robbed and you'll
see how cool this guy acts and this guy
has no idea it's can run he didn't give
him his phone yeah he'll be very oh let
me refresh her probably back but I saw
this video it's [ __ ] great there we
are let me tell you where's the guy with
the gun
he's gonna come in in a bit he's in
frame he's not in frame yet but he
walked I see that he's already holding
up his hands okay Oh hammered so he's
just taking a sip out of his beer
look see he's playing a video on his
phone yeah bright he's on his phone just
chi'lan it's kind of a longer video dude
it's [ __ ] let me fast forward here
the guy has that guys take his phone he
rips his phone away from the guy who's
holding a machine gun
the guy has a machine gun in his hand
and he continues smokers holy [ __ ] he
just doesn't care
yeah that man I guess probably military
or something like his soft girlfriend at
home pissed-off wife and this is his
time he needs this time damn he's just
chillin sawed-off shotguns what that is
oh that's not a machine gun that's 15
years old
that's a they checked out later on it's
actually a pistol but it they turned it
in to make it look like an actual rifle
I mean this guy's just talking [ __ ] to
him yeah he's gonna just kind of mean
like whatever and does the guy shoot
anybody
no he just wants to get people's money
so the cieariy he has this guy's back
the guys still chilling smoking a
cigarette damn I can't buy this video so
grainy now he didn't hit him or nothing
hey also these these these [ __ ] cams
these and breastaurant and stuff dude a
header oh that's better
oh now see his face I mean they're like
buddies now they're like talking yeah I
just talking and even now this guy lit
up a cigarette too stressed out bro
where's this at what seamless service
this guy didn't wear a mask or nothing
nope so anyways the moral story is this
guy just doesn't care and he wouldn't
let him take his phone or his money damn
that he wouldn't take his money
no you wouldn't let him cool custom he
points at him right there god I respect
it that or that bartend were scared as
[ __ ] yeah he was super scared I'd be
scared what else yeah how would you you
guys ever had a gun pulled on you yeah
no you really you know really are
thinking up some cool story I have a
story but I didn't know the gun was
pulled so I was acting as if the guy
didn't pull the gun yet yeah it's pretty
wild it happened to us see happen here
and later that night some kid got shot
what happened I just bumped into some
guy and I was being like you know stupid
like New York [ __ ] old roof guy
college probably like 19 or something
like that and this guy bumps into me and
then you know I was like what's up then
and he pulled out the gun and put it on
his side but I didn't see him do that
so I'm like I do something about it and
my boy is just going like hey Angie
let's just go let's just walk away oh my
god I [ __ ] it whatever they didn't want
any and then my boys like like broke you
know the guy had a [ __ ] gun and
cheese and then later that night
somebody got shot on the [ __ ] god
yeah in that area kind of crazy that's a
bad area uh just some blood robbed me my
three my other two white friends because
wearing all red really yeah you still
got that red supreme hat on yeah yeah
what's up now bro what's up now that's a
frame rate you're crazy man those are
blood Oh cuz you had red we had red on
but he did we he was like why y'all
flamed up why the [ __ ] you don't we're
not here you ain't from this set I was
like what is happening I like this old
navy jacket please don't take it and he
was take the jackets off take the jacket
off you know spit on him and I was like
yeah right I was all like faking on and
like one white friend who's so scared
and richer dude have a little pride
forget that one wasn't [ __ ] a mall
parking lot
ah we were young freshmen high school oh
you were in Denver
yeah [ __ ] man what else you get well you
know this story everyone knows the story
right CEO of Twitter
Dorsey his Twitter account was hacked I
saw people tweeting about this you know
it's posting some sort of racist stuff
to what did they say I'll show you the
tweets right here chuckling squad it's
hashtag chuckling squad get attorney for
his Twitter password then they did a
bomb threat at Twitter headquarters and
then this was the racist one which is
just an old Asian dude that's racist
that's right that's what they consider
racist just cuz he posted a what's her
name that one nation well that one
feminist who put a man is not a woman as
a man is not a woman and she got banned
from Twitter for life for that old and
uh crap I'm talking about
she's a young girl right that one yes
she's like a feminist who was like
saying that that men who become women
shouldn't be in the feminist space cuz
all in their minds I think if someone
else I'm so but this is all I did is
hack and post this yeah Wow
but I mean the fact that they got the
Twitter is account yeah that's a result
to this Asian guy
his face is so Asian its racist there's
even more
what is chuckling squad what is that
that's just the hashtag they were going
for that's right there's a new Volvo
that broke into it but the actual the
thing that broke into it was something
else that was the before Twitter started
it was its what Twitter bought like the
company they bought to help their SMS
system out oh that makes any sense I'm
already [ __ ] going on right now yeah so
cloud hopper wasn't in ok that's what it
required between via the oldest I mean
what a waste of God just a really dodged
a Bunny's [ __ ] where I ain't like you
know let mid party or something come on
bro come on get in there let's call it
Zuckerberg is talking about Zuckerberg
you know his account was hacked back in
like 2016 or something and they found
out his password was the most simple
password ever it was just da da da da da
da da da da what was he think is what
their kid would say to him I guess when
the baby would call him dad a dad like
that he just used that password no super
easy to break through are you sure it's
not data data data
it was da du always seemed like and
thinking Brian okay you get at expert
Peter Thiel shut your [ __ ] mouth it
was one more all right you guys know
Kacey Musgraves yeah she's incredibly
popular she's super huge she was in
Koreatown and there's stuff today
I know she found a little tiny like
every every week anyway this is the
influence this is what representation is
about Stacy she's not get to know Kacey
Musgraves that she's super hot too so
what did she do she found this little
like hole in the wall mom-and-pop shop
for making photos you know our delivery
photo whatever our development yeah and
as it Vietnamese family - but that's a
they only take cash they have no
wireless internet nothing like that it's
an old shop that's been there for a long
time together guys how about that yeah
so she's like get it together
good point her parents also come from a
story once she posted about it so she
did these pictures at that place right
okay yeah yeah I thought this is a this
is a shop right there oh there
she's juggling all this like hey check
this out yeah they were struggling Thank
You posted now that of course they just
blew up
oh that's what she didn't realize is
they were a front for drugs thank you
Vietnamese business fronts we all know
how this works you think flow was like
it's supposed to be a profitable
business no it was a faux business okay
they actually have drugs running right
that's why they [ __ ] called at that
and now she just blew it up yeah she
just snitched on the game blow now he's
gonna sell [ __ ] photographs % Wow
she's a big deal this white here complex
really yeah man what is up with that I
don't know she's cute though
she's very very penny followers 1.6 she
got some lips on her yes she does she
got some ellipse mm-hmm diesels Pam just
country singer but then it's kind of
crossing over into pop - but country
she's very very very pretty
oh wow mouths you look at you like an
Andrew I like I like hottie
yes she's a hottie how many followers
can you think so my team's one point
happenin boss she might see your damn I
don't think so
you got blue checkmark I got blue check
but still you know there's ratio
brothers a ratio you know she might like
funny guys I never know is that you guys
go anymore
that was I sent a picture of Bryan's
feet yeah jeans you about the [ __ ] we're
regressing with your style we're going
back to jeans sandals no no I it's just
hot today and I threw them on in a hurry
that's all I want to wear pants with
sandals in my house really nope we got
to get the mail like that we're not
Burke's
you go Burt you know that's good she put
out a line he wouldn't he bought a pair
of boots with a buckle on him from Gucci
never warm again you warm once I think
right I wear them all the time you do if
I were I'm not wear boots this do I wear
mother really yeah I love those boots
have you ever tried Burke's Birkenstock
oh you got a Burke - wait for me nice
stop oh you got a Burke come from me
dude come
it's different it's not like flip-flops
it's not like slides
it's bird that's wide open it's like a
combination he's got double straps you
actually feel you could do something you
could like you could fight if you need
like a real you know it's called a what
can you run them you need to birds get
comments dude is a communist why are
those Burke's five huh
300 [ __ ] they're made to your foot nah
man I don't know dudes and sandals just
so no no that's not saying that's how
you got to stop
that's Burke's that's a different guy
looks pretty cool hey Bryce is right
there aren't you man right there killin
it that's it who that be dude that's
refined what are you gonna wear if
you're there's a bird inside there's a
Birkenstock store on a bikini hey hey
so get them let's get some irons medic
Tevas but don't wear though yeah I think
you can you're past that you're more
refined than that yeah you're a perk
you're better
yeah yeah but you could Burke that's the
thing that you don't realize you can
Burke and my toes dog is different it's
your toes already been vulnerable and
you start a not vulnerable summer's over
bro the ledge the ledge protects your
toe you see at the front there's that
little edge you're not stubbing your toe
not even one time there are not even one
time you step in your toe and your heel
there's that little hook right there
that's daily like Jesus shoes yeah say
what it look like Jesus hey soos in an
emergency maybe but that is you never
have animal or sex it's a different life
I had lots of boat colored shirt huh
to eunuch bro that's too much that's too
much that's it that's a commitment
that's too much well but those I'm dude
dude I'm leaving Tuesday night let's go
shopping
now they can find your new special on
YouTube yeah my the only place to get it
mother's the Andrew Schultz that's it go
check it out man 35 minutes special I
also love how it's 35 minutes an hour
it's just simply too long too long the
longer she got hard to Kemah even for an
hour it's tough you got a build up to it
that's my 35 though it's perfect I'm 30
I'm like how much longer five on it I
can finish that I feel you bro you got
to earn people's attention oh yeah yeah
you do buddy
thank you grats on the special man you
[ __ ] cam their shoulder where you
gonna be on the road everything sold out
were you doing yeah man I'm going to
Russia next week Moscow that's gonna be
cool then we're going to Australia for a
couple weeks
I'd also do a North Melbourne Crispin's
and then come back to Cali and then but
yeah we just got to keep going man it's
been really I'm stoked man we just sold
out the New York show in town hall so
that was pretty [ __ ] cool well you
did the show already in town no no no
it's in November 22nd so good for you
man we'll see what happens to that but
I'm just I'm just stoked man the end
result stuck on four tickets if you guys
want to come and one of the best thank
you David we love you thanks for coming
on brother appreciate you guys have me
this is the fire and kid we're out